good morning believe nation today's
message is be yourself and now over to
you take home use addition period any
artist I think just absolutely do what's
in your heart
period say what's on your mind speak
what's in your heart and how you really
feel when you're trying to be something
else we trying to fit in to what's going
on it's like you kind of stray away from
your path a little bit sometimes you
want to expand your style and like grow
and that's always good but like never
veer too far from who you are
you know as a as a person so what do you
think here's the thing have you heard
this expression there's an expression
out there that says basically like be
yourself because everyone else has taken
I like that one you know what I mean I
like that one too
for me personally I spent a lot of sort
of the earlier part of my life like into
my 20s kind of feeling like I had to be
something that someone else wanted me to
be like I had to be this version of
myself that my parents expected me to be
and I got to this point in my life when
I was in my late 20s and I was just like
you know what this isn't working for me
like it is not working for me and so in
my 30s and now into my 40s I've just
found forties whoa hey there I'm 29 I'm
clearly 29 look at this I'm clearly 29
as I get older I just find that I'm able
to be more confident in Who I am and be
okay about the fact that this is who I
am
and it's okay to just be myself right if
you guys look back at my youtube channel
you notice I talked about the similar
stuff the same points the same values
that I had was always been constant but
I've turned up a lot more I'm more
energetic more more of an activist maybe
more passionate energy and it's just
having confidence in not worrying what
other people think we had a discussion
last night and that was fun and we kind
of got in which had a little bit there
but it's all out of love and an
understanding that like I am trying to
send my message
there to help people and not everybody's
gonna get that no one's gonna understand
that but for the most part it wins and I
think too many people are afraid of how
their opinion is going to be judged and
how it's going to be seen and so they
they just melt down into you know not
the worst version of themselves but the
weakest version of themselves where have
more confidence in your opinion and
practice speaking out and practice when
you see something you don't like
expressing yourself and have the
confidence that your intention is right
and that for the most part things will
work out what Evan Carmichael just said
all right so the question of the day
today is is there ever a time when being
yourself is too much like being too much
of yourself do you know what I mean so
I'll give you a really quick example a
lot of people have struggles in their
lives and I respect that
they're going through a tough time and
sometimes people talk about that and
post that on social media is there a
time when it's too much like are there
times when you should not put that stuff
on social media is there times when you
know it might be too negative and that
it might have a negative impact on who
you are and your brand so for me I'm
always like trying to figure out what's
that balance between being accessible
between being transparent but also like
is there a time when you can literally
be too much of yourself on social media
let us know leaving the comments below
we will join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching and have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of ENSO
they spray so give me go